le monde de la culture s'émeut que
depuis le 30 octobre
les musées soit fermée au public tous
les musées du château de versailles au
musée du tire bouchon dans le lubéron
l'amateur d'art et de culture trouve
porte close et c'est là que le maire
rassemblement national de perpignan
louis aliot tente de se faire une place
dans le débat en montrant qu'il soutient
le monde la culture pour ce faire eh
bien il a pris cette semaine un arrêté
de réouverture des musées municipaux de
la ville
sauf que c'est illégal pourquoi et bien
pour comprendre il faut se plonger dans
la répartition des pouvoirs entre le
maire et le gouvernement
par principe le maire dispose de ce
qu'on appelle un pouvoir de police
générale
en d'autres termes c'est à lui en
premier lieu qui revient de protéger
l'ordre public ou encore la santé
publique
le premier magistrat de la ville est
donc celui qui est en première ligne
pour la protection de ses administrés ce
qui explique l'existence des polices
municipales ou encore qu'il revienne au
maire de décider de la fermeture de la
piscine pour cause de pollution de l'eau
on pourrait donc se dire qu'en vertu de
ce pouvoir de police générale
louis aliot pouvait en estimant que le
respect des gestes barrières suffirait à
protéger la santé des perpignanais
décidé de rouvrir ses musées sauf que
tout pouvoir à une limite et que la
limite de ce pouvoir de police générale
ici elle est fixée par le pouvoir de
police spéciale du gouvernement en
matière sanitaire le code de la santé
publique dans lé en effet à l'état le
pouvoir de prendre des décisions qui
s'imposent à tous pour protéger la santé
des français
et si l'état agit et bien le maire est
obligé de suivre c'est ce qu'on appelle
la hiérarchie des normes
c'est exactement le même principe qui
s'applique est lorsque les mères ont un
peu partout en france décidé de rouvrir
les commerces et le sort de la décision
de louis aliot sur les musées connaîtra
le même sort
l'annulation pure et simple par le juge
et la fermeture immédiate des musées de
la ville